as Ronald Reagan said the problem with
our liberal friends is not that they are
ignorant it's just that they know so
much that isn't
so we went through the woke Christmas
tick toks of a Creator by the name of
Cassandra and because you all enjoyed
the thorough debunking so much we have
decided to take on Cassandra's
historical musings about one of my
favorite men in
[Music]
history
historical figures terrible people
Christopher Columbus all right let's
start off with the least uncomfortable
fact he thought manatees were mermaids
and you try to date one put pause there
there is no evidence that Christopher
Columbus thought manatees were mermaids
Christopher
Columbus said that he saw mermaids and
liberal scientistic mother squishes have
pretended that what he saw was a manity
he may have just seen a mermaid he
didn't try to date the Mermaid by the
way try to date a manity or mermaid but
I don't know why people are so convinced
that the man saw a manate manatees and
mermaids don't look very similar and I
think there's at least there's at least
a 10% shot he just he just saw a mermaid
keep going he thought Earth was shaped
like a boob and the top part was the nip
and the top part also so happened to be
Eden like the biblical Eden put a pause
right there I'm glad at least she's not
saying that he thought that the Earth
was flat or that everyone thought the
Earth was flat but Columbus had the
suspicion that maybe it wasn't flat and
all I'm I'm glad cuz that just isn't
true that's a ton of misinformation
people thought the world was flat for
quite out loud so what's interesting
here is that she's saying Christopher
Columbus is a big dummy because he
thought that the Earth wasn't perfectly
spherical spherical but of course the
Earth is not perfectly spherical the
Earth has topography right the Earth has
mountains the Earth has valleys the
Earth has volcanoes the Earth has all of
that so if her argument against Columbus
is Christopher Columbus was a big stupid
idiot because he thought there were
mountains on Earth which obviously there
are but he thought one of the mountains
was really really big like okay how
could you I I want this lady to draw me
a map of the Earth and I want her to get
the topography exactly right good luck
lady I think Columbus is going to be a
lot more right than you are keep going
he created one of the first slavery
Rings many of these slaves were sold to
his friends who were known murderers but
it was there he created one of the first
slavery rings are you insane the man
sailed the ocean blew in 1492 slavery
has existed since the dawn of man
especially in Africa subsaharan Africa
and Northern Africa though it existed
everywhere in the world it existed in
the Americas long before Christopher
Columbus ever got there and furthermore
slavery continues to exist today
everywhere outside of the west but he
says he created one of the first slave
Rings Where do you think he got the
slaves from slaves he got slaves from
Native Americans some of whom were
already enslaved or who were being
attacked captured and cannibalized in
some cases by those wonderful natives
the world word cannibalism comes from
the carab Islanders and then as slavery
developed in the New World New Slaves
were imported from Africa where did they
get those slaves they got those slaves
from other Africans who had been
enslaving them keep going he forced
natives to work in gold mines and he
considered them his property the way he
treated natives was absolutely barbaric
he would test the sharpness of his
blades on them throw them in Vats of
boiling soap I mean beheadings just the
most put pause there yes there was this
this system the encomenda system and
other systems of forc Labor in the
America is a lot of it was about getting
gold the purpose of getting gold though
by the way was not so that Columbus
could buy a core debt it was so that
Columbus could fund another Crusade so
the Christians could retake the Holy
Land from the Muslims who had conquered
it which I think is a absolutely
virtuous and Valiant good good cause to
be used for with this gold but
furthermore Christopher Columbus though
he is accused of all this awful
mistreatment of the Native Americans
more often than not was actually the
defender of the Native Americans against
the Spaniards who had come with him and
who were running this Colony so the
worst sort of claims against Christopher
Columbus in this regard come from a man
named Francisco de bobadilla Francisco
de bobadilla though was the guy who took
Columbus's job as the governor of the
Americans so Francisco de bobadilla was
the guy who was Columbus's Chief
political rival it would be like looking
at the crimes of Hillary Clinton and
relying only on the Diaries of Donald
Trump or vice versa the crimes of Donald
Trump relying only on the Diaries of
Hillary Clinton that is simply not
reliable and there are many cases
recorded of the Spaniards trying to
torture and kill Native Americans and
Columbus would come in on their side I
think the the best Authority on this
matter is bolom deas kazas who is the
first resident Bishop of the Americas
who remained a Columbus admirer and
Defender until the end and Bol delas
kazus is considered one of the greatest
defend of natives in American history
keep going he even used these humans as
dog food there was about 10,000 people
that he did this to when he first met
the arox he wrote that they were
peaceful handsome and they traded
everything they owned He also mentioned
that they didn't have swords and with 50
of his men he could do whatever he
wanted with them after these people
showed him nothing but kindness when he
ran out of money and he needed funding
his writing complet put a pause there so
when Columbus first met the tyos and the
other natives around the Caribbean it is
true he said these people are very
simple we'll be able to conquered them
very easily he said he said things like
this he also told the Spaniards not to
take advantage of them you see this in
very reliable historical accounts
especially admiral of the ocean sea by
Samuel Elliot Morrison a very very
respected Harvard historian so yes he
was engaged in a mission of Conquest
that is true but he wasn't some
genocidal psychosexual killer or
anything like that okay that is a bunch
of nonsense and in many many cases he
was the one one urging charity and
prudence and restraint keep going he
wrote that they're evil Savage cannibals
with doglike noses who drink the blood
of their victims put pause there some of
them were some of them were not the tyo
Indians but the carobs were they were
cannibals they were Savage cannibals who
would eat the tyos the T he noticed
Columbus saw when he arrived that the
tyo Indians had marks on their bodies
and he said where'd you get those marks
from and they they got the marks from
these Maniac Arab Islanders from whom we
get the word cannibal you know so maybe
this lady doesn't like that but to quote
my colleague over here facts don't care
about her feelings keep going also
historians are pretty sure he wasn't
even
Italian he was a brave Italian explorer
he wasn't even good at speaking or
writing Italian and they believe he was
the illegitimate son of a Portuguese oh
my goodness put a pause there histori
give me a break what histori she you
notice she doesn't site the historians
because there aren't any all of the top
Columbus historians are quite convinced
that the man was Italian he may not have
written Italian very well but he didn't
write Italian very well cuz the man
didn't come from a ton of means the man
was largely self-educated and he wrote
in Spanish I mean he became a Spanish
sailor though he was an Italian himself
keep going he also never even stepped
foot in what we know as a United States
He landed in the Caribbean so big
misconception is that a put a pause
there who who thinks that Christopher
Columbus walked around New
York I'm walking here who thinks nobody
thinks that no Columbus Defender thinks
that it's only the big Libs who hate
Columbus who pretend like this is a a
big misconception just like the libs who
say you know all these dumb people used
to think the Earth was flat what a
misconception that was no they didn't
people have known that the Earth is
roughly
spherical since Antiquity okay it's not
you're you're the one with the
misconception about people's
misconceptions keep going after his
horrific crimes he was taken back to
Spain and shackles but he was forgiven
so graciously that they even gave him
his own holiday because they thought the
good outweighed the bad okay put a pause
was there no the Spanish didn't the
Columbus Day holiday to which I assume
she was referring was established in
1891 in the United States because there
was a mass lynching of italian-americans
in Louisiana and then the the Columbus
holiday kept cropping up every so off in
the 1930s it cropped up under FDR and so
they established it as as a holiday for
Italians though it was actually a
holiday just to give Italians a little
bit of a feeling that they were welcomed
into the country Columbus Day is a day
of Italian Pride Columbus was sent back
shackles because Boba out foxed him in
the Americas and took his job and sent
him back and Columbus was absolutely
Furious about this and he wrote in his
diaries that he said if there is any
justice whatsoever these people will all
burn in hell for what they've done to me
for the slander and and defamation that
they have undertaken and also by the way
he wasn't forgiven so graciously that
did not happen even from the wonderful
monarchs Ferdinand and Isabella Columbus
made it back but part of the reason that
he was was kept in his shackles part of
the reason why I think the crown was so
inclined to believe bobadilla was
because the crown owned Columbus a lot
of money and so if if they were able to
accuse him of a crime they wouldn't they
would be far more justified in not
giving him all of the money that they
owed him keep going it is now 2021 and
for the life of me I cannot figure out
why this man still has a holiday right
you can't figure it out because you
don't know anything about how the
holiday was established you don't know
anything about who the man was or what
the man did or your own civiliz
without without this man you would not
be here okay you don't know anything
about any of
that so you can't figure out why he's
got a holiday maybe you should first
learn all those things about the man and
who he was and what he did and what his
relation is to you and then you might
have a greater appreciation of him I'm
Michael NES this is the Michael nlls
show we see you
[Music]
tomorrow